we've seen previously that if the rope
is under tension and we approximate the
rope is massless that the tension is
then uniform everywhere along the rope
even if the rope is accelerated however
if the rope has nonzero mass then its
tension will vary along its length we
can see that and by looking at this
example of imagine we have a massive
rope of length L suspended from a
ceiling now it's easy to see that at the
top of the rope a little little element
of rope right at the top has to support
the entire weight of the entire rope so
if I were to examine just a little piece
at the top here the weight of the entire
rope would be acting downwards and for
the rope to remain stationary there has
to be a tension upwards I'll call this T
top because this is at the top of the
rope and so we see immediately from that
that at the top of the rope the tension
is just equal to mg where m is the mass
of the entire rope similarly if we asked
what the tension is at the bottom of the
rope an element right at the bottom of
the rope isn't supporting any weight
because there's no weight below it and
so at the bottom the tension is zero
because there's no weight pulling on the
bottom of the rope so the tension is
going to vary from mg at the top down to
zero at the bottom and if we wanted to
work out at some distance from the
ceiling let's call it X at some position
X say here what the tension is at that
point one way of figuring that out would
just be imagine we cut the rope at this
point and then asked what what tension
force would be necessary to support this
bottom part of the rope
this length is L minus X so the mass of
that fraction of the Rope is L minus x
over L and the mass of that fraction of
the rope is that fraction times M and so
the tension at this point T at X is
equal to the weight of the length of
rope below that point so that's this
mass times G and I can rewrite that as 1
minus x over L times mg okay and this
gives me mg if I put in x equals 0 and
it gives me 0 if I put in x equals L so
that's one way of figuring this out I'd
like to use the same example though to
introduce another more elegant way of
analyzing what the tension is as a
function of position on this rope and
the advantage so this is going to be a
little bit more complicated but it's a
much more powerful method and it's one
that we can generally use for any
continuous distribution of mass as
opposed to a point mass so let's
consider the same example again of a
hanging mass of rope of length L and
mass M
there's the length L and the mass m and
the approach we're going to use is
called differential analysis it's a
technique from calculus and it's
applicable to any continuous
distribution of mass what we're going to
do is imagine our continuous
distribution of mass is made up of a
whole bunch of little pieces little
elements examine F equals MA acting on a
single element and then generalize to
the entire to the entire mass so let's
do that here what we'll do is we'll
examine a piece at some position X so
I'm measuring X from the top and let's
say I define a little element here which
is that position X and which has an
extent Delta X so this thickness is
Delta X and we'll call the mass of that
little piece that little element Delta M
okay now one thing I want to point out
to begin with is that we want to pick an
element that somewhere in the middle of
the distribution not at one end of the
other the endpoints are special cases so
we want to pick a general case so choose
some X somewhere in the middle of our
distribution and which has a finite
extent that extent is Delta X in this
case we'll assume about piece Delta X
has a mass Delta M so let's blow that up
here and analyze it so here's my element
and it's going to have let's analyze
what the force is acting on it R so
there's gravity acting downwards which
will be Delta M times G there is a
tension acting upwards exerted by the
rope above it this is I'll write that as
T of X because it's at the location X
there's also a tension exerted in the
downward direction by the remainder of
the rope below the mass element
and I'll call that T of X plus Delta X
we expect the tension to vary along the
rope and because this element does have
a finite extent the tension at the
bottom is going to be slightly different
than the tension at the top okay so G of
X upwards to U of X plus Delta X
downwards and then the weight downwards
all right so let's now that's our
Freebody diagram let's write down
Newton's second law F equals MA for that
mass element so in the positive
direction which is downward we have T of
X plus Delta X plus Delta mg and then in
the upward or minus direction we have
minus T of X so those are the combined
forces now this rope is suspended it's
not moving and so the mass times
acceleration is just zero I'm gonna
rearrange that I can write that as T of
X plus Delta X minus T of X is equal to
minus Delta M times G and by the way let
me remind you if this were a massless
rope then Delta M would be zero and so
the right hand side would be zero and
the tension would be uniform we'd have
the same tension above and below but
because the rope does have mass and in
particular this element has a map
nonzero mass Delta M there's a
difference in the tensions okay now our
Delta M can be represented in terms of
what this length is notice that that
mass Delta M so note that Delta M is
just a fraction of the total mass that's
in that particular mass element well the
fraction of the total rope is just the
length of this element Delta X divided
by the length of the entire rope which
is L so that's the fraction and I
multiply that by the total mass so that
is my mass Delta M in terms of the
length so now I can rewrite this
Rajon as T of X plus Delta X minus T of
X is equal to minus Delta X M over L
times G now I'm going to rearrange this
by dividing both sides by Delta X I'll
do that over here so we have T of X plus
Delta X minus T of X divided by Delta X
is equal to minus M G over L this tells
us how the tension is varying over this
small but finite sized mass element
Delta X now I'd like to examine what
happens if I go to the limit of a small
master element where so in the limit as
Delta X goes to 0 or in other words the
limit of an infinitesimally small mass
element so I'm going to take the limit
of this equation as Delta X approaches 0
now the left-hand side of this equation
should look familiar it's just an
expression for the derivative of the
tension T as a function of position so I
can write that as DT DX and that's equal
to minus mg over L this is an example of
a differential equation or an equation
that involves a derivative this
particular differential equation can be
solved very simply by a technique called
the separation of variables where I just
take each part of the integral the DT
and the DX and put it on different sides
of the equation and then integrate both
sides of the equation to find the
solution so in this case I'll multiply
both sides of the equation by DX so I
get DT on the left-hand side is equal to
minus M G over L DX
and now I want to integrate both sides
so I'll integrate this side and remember
mg over L is a constant so I can keep it
outside the integral now integrate this
side I'm going to do a definite integral
over the continuous distribution that
I'm studying so on the right hand side
I'm going to start at x equals zero and
go to my position of interest which is X
and to avoid confusion I'm going to call
the integration variable DX Prime this
is a dummy variable so X prime here
represents all the values of position
ranging from my first endpoint zero up
to my other endpoint X okay so X here
represents a particular position whereas
DX prime is a placeholder for all the
positions between the two endpoints in
my infinite sum which is an integral
okay so that's on the right hand side on
the left hand side I'm integrating the
tension T with respect to the tension T
my limits need to correspond to the
limits on the right hand side integral
okay so on the right hand side my lower
limit is at x equals zero so on the left
hand side I want to have my lower limit
be the tension at that position x equals
zero so that's T of zero and then the
upper limit of the integral is the
tension at the upper limit of the
position integral so that's T of X and
again to avoid confusion I'm marcha
going to call the integration variable
DT Prime this is a dummy variable it's a
placeholder for all the values of
tension from the tension at x equals
zero to the tension at my position of
interest X okay so this integral now
tells me how the tension is varying in a
continuous fashion along this continuous
mass distribution so now I can evaluate
both integrals on this side I have the
integral of a constant with respect to
the tension and so that's just going to
give me t of X minus T of 0 and that's
equal to minus M G over L the integral
of DX prime from 0 to X
is just X okay so this tells me how the
tension changes from the endpoint to
some arbitrary position X if I want to
actually solve for T of X I need to
specify what the tension is at the
endpoint but we know what the tension is
at the endpoint we found that earlier we
solve in the simple argument that at the
endpoint the tension here is just equal
to the weight of the entire length of
rope below that point so we know that T
at x equals zero is just equal to mg and
therefore the tension at position X is
just if I bring to you of zero to this
side is just M G minus mg x over L and
so I can just write that as mg times one
minus x over L so that tells me what the
tension is as a function of position
note again that if I put in x equals
zero I just get mg if I put in x equals
L I get the tension is 0 and for any
point in between we see that the tension
varies smoothly between mg and zero this
is exactly the same result we found
earlier by just cutting the rope at X
and asking how do we balance the weight
of the remaining rope below that point
but the advantage of this technique
which is a little bit more complicated
is that it's a very powerful technique
applicable to any continuous
distribution of mass so in this specific
problem if instead of the uniform
density rope that we have here imagine
we had a clumpy rope where the the the
mass of the Rope wasn't distributed
smoothly but was you know there were
clumps there were little parts of the
rope that were heavier than others and
so the density of sort of varied with
position along the rope
in that case we would represent that
when we were writing what our mass
element Delta M is Delta M instead of
just being Delta x over L times M where
here Delta x over L is the uniform
density of the rope we would have to put
in some position dependent density so
Delta M would depend upon position and
then when I did this integral instead of
a constant out front with my integral of
DX Prime I would have some thing that
was a function of X and I'd get a
different value for the integral but the
technique would still work so this
differential analysis technique is
applicable to any system where we have a
continuous mass distribution and we're
going to actually use this technique
over and over again in this course we'll
see it a number of times this is just
the first instant we're using if we
wanted to introduce you carefully to the
approach